baby okay-y vegan junk food maybe even
worse for your health because junk food
is junk food is junk food right
but hold on hold on so here's the thing
Adams vegan and the first thing we both
said when I saw this article because
it's from just a few days ago it's like
why vegan junk food mate maybe even
worse for your health
what junk food is bad for you yeah like
you know Oreos are vegan yeah it's like
okay if you eat nothing but Oreos you're
gonna get sick no it's sour patch kids
are vegan also I think but but but I
think I mean you should eat them all but
here's the thing about fad veganism hmm
right so fad veganism is people thinking
you just don't eat meat and you're gonna
be healthier right and then said enough
like not the case taking vitamins
yeah there's certain protein gonna do
you also have to eat more yeah because
you you need to eat more vegetables and
you know to consume the amount of
calories and stuff you need it's you
have to understand based nutrition you
can't just like I'm just gonna cut meat
out of my diet and but here's the thing
that'd be that while we look at the
surface of this article we're like oh
come on junk foods bad for you we get it
they slept vegan in front of our
clickbait there's actually an
interesting truth here you may have
heard about you know Burger King doing
the impossible burger yeah it's got a
ton of sodium it is actually it's not
surprising right BK what are you shaking
your head oh you're saying yes yeah this
guy's want to show you so what they're
basically saying is that vegan junk food
which is kind of strange because Oreos
are vegan sour patch kids are vegan what
else is vegan like Swedish fish right
like all these all these starch candies
like come on man
no one's no one's complaining with that
stuff but it's not so much junk food
it's it's fast food right so let's let's
read BBC says well while we might switch
to a plant-based diet with the best
intentions the unseen risks of vegan
fast food might not show up for years no
British train station or high street
would be complete without a Gregg's
bakery the merchants of mass produced
pastries are as quintessential as they
come in last year they won plaudits for
turning vegan on the back of their
success other fast food brands shortly
followed suit in fact Gregg's vegan
sausage rolls have been so successful
the company announced a phenomenal year
for sale
in 2019 driven in part by their new
products that they would that they would
share a seven million pound bonus
equally between staff wow that's amazing
vegan food that's nuts
I gotta say that that chow that's good
that's good stuff it's good stuff it
really is like the sausage roll another
staple of British fast food fish and
chips has had a vegan makeover no no no
you're not gonna see me replacing cod or
haddock with the plant-based tofu
sometimes also with a layer of crispy
nori seaweed to create the effect of
fish skin mmm that's probably good
vegans can now enjoy tow fish with their
chips I mean it's a lot of things you
can make yeah they might sound like a
guilt-free alternative or a gateway to
the vegan curious but vegan fast food
alternatives are often worse for your
health and the meat equivalent obviously
the pros are that veganism is getting
people to think about plant-based foods
but the con is that it makes us think
that it is good for you when it can be
equally or more unhealthy said night
says Megan Rossi a dietitian at King's
College London and author of eat
yourself healthy tofu contains omega-3
but it is a type that is not as active
as animal sources says Rossi plant-based
sources contain a type of omega-3 called
alpha Lindo linolenic acid ala for our
bodies to be able to do anything
particularly useful with ala ala we need
to convert it into I'm not reading that
what is it a a cosas pentatonic not bad
it's a pent a no ik ACO sapanta no ik
acid there you go
and dokgo saw heck's a on ik acid a DHA
however humans are not particularly well
equipped to do this if that means Adam
they're saying you got it you have to do
it that's okay I eat a lot of vegetables
but would you would you eat lab-grown
meat I don't I don't miss meat I don't I
don't have a desire for meat you know
that's not and you know that I haven't I
went meat free and you know I'm I'm
excited when I have the beyond sausage
because I think it's just really
delicious protein but it's P protein
protein you know but I don't go out of
my way to put it in every single meal
that I'm having you know
it's not it's not something I think
about and now now that I'm like and I'm
constantly reading and and furthering my
knowledge about food so if I'm finding
out that there's some vegan alternatives
that aren't healthy I'm gonna cut them
out of my diet also yeah the main reason
I went vegan is for health
I just learned too much too quickly to
go why am I even consuming these
products well I would agree with you on
a lot of them but how do you feel about
you know what like Joe Rogan and Jordan
Peterson have tried to in the carnivore
diet they claim they're even healthier I
know that that that post that Joe Rogan
had and he's like I've only eaten meat
for one month and I feel fantastic and
it's like that's that's incredible
that's it's shocking but it is also
everybody
I also know that he's one person and we
are billions of people you know so the
the science that I've seen and read
about is you know showing a lean towards
we're not meat eaters we're plant eaters
angry that's the science that I've read
is what I'm referring to
yeah so all these articles that I've
read and it's like alright I'm gonna
keep I feel great I can agree in which I
know yeah I mean and one thing it's like
when I one nice when there's like a
cheese that I consumed on accident like
I it's very few and far between now but
like my gas is terrible so bad it's yeah
cuz the lactose shopping you know I'm
yeah I don't have dairy anymore but I
can tell when there's something like
within an hour to eating something that
may or may not have that dairy in it I
could tell you if it did by just you
know I guess I've tried it's bad I've
tried doing vegetarianism and veganism
mmm-hmm makes me sick that's not for you
that's fine yeah okay yeah yeah yeah I
write so I can you know I think if you
if you're you know reading about stuff
and it's healthy and ultimately I'm a
very libertarian minded person so it's
like I don't care what you eat man I
knew I knew one dude who's vegan it's
like he ate ramen all the time and like
sounds terribly unwell the spice isn't
vegan he would put hot sauce on it
right and yeah and you would eat like
you know Oreos and I'm like I don't
think you're really a vegan I think
you're just eating disgusting food and
you're gonna get that doesn't sound help
that's not a help it that's what
what people do I knew a ton of people
growing up who are like oh I'm gonna go
vegan and then and then what they do is
they eat just like anything that doesn't
have they have no pets no vitamins thick
no but for me it's like I think the
research I think for me it was probably
just really hard to maintain a balanced
complete diet mm-hmm for me to do that
you know it's like but it's not easy
meat is a cheap and easy path to a ton
of stuff you need mm-hmm well let's read
this cuz I want to read this or some
more of this basically ragged on the
vegans they say plant-based protein
sources usually lack at least one of the
nine essential amino acids but rice and
beans has everything right can't you
just see rice and beans doesn't have b12
though it doesn't Robotech yeah right
okay let's read that's not an amino acid
no true they say this means that vegans
either need to carefully balance their
proteins so they can complement it okay
this is dumb you know why I don't I
don't think we need a lecture on why a
vegan should or shouldn't or what they
need to do I think if you're a vegan you
take care of yourself what i want what i
Morstan it is are people gonna go buy
burgers from Burger King and get sick
because of it right for the record also
those those burgers that Burger King are
not vegan
they are plant plant-based burgers
that's what they say but they're they're
cooking them on the same right right you
know it's like cooking an animal grease
it's like the same thing it's like did
you hear what was it was it Tim Hortons
I got out of it you know who what it was
there was a big chain I think was Tim
Hortons they got rid of their vegan
because nobody was buying it mmm and
what they think happened is you do this
big PR push for this fancy new product
people are gonna buy it and then a month
later people are gonna just not think
twice yeah exactly shop and be like
sausage burger yeah you got it they're
not gonna be like specialty vegan
sausage please right I mean there is
those few and far between people like
myself that may ask for it but hey I'm
not going out and eating at a restaurant
anyway I'm not going to Tim Hortons like
why would I ever go there because I I
don't get the the vibe that they're
gonna have something that I'm gonna walk
out I feeling satisfied I got to say
this okay I was expecting the BBC to
give us an article talking about how you
know it's a fact that
there are these these vegan versions
that are high in some things low and
other things and they're bad for you you
know like one of the big concerns about
the impossible burger mhm I could be
wrong don't don't get me how to be
impossible burgers is that it really has
a ton of salt like it has like 90
percent of your daily salt like a
ridiculous amount or like someone's
crazy I mean do you know that I think I
McDonald's cheeseburger has like 90
percent of your daily sodium intake Wow
like some ridiculous number Google don't
see like what the percent yeah it's
ridiculous like you eat two burgers and
you're beyond your salt intake but this
article is just ragging on vegans I'm
like dude I don't yeah it's like all
fast food is terrible
no buts not even doing that like I got
to this point where I'm reading it I'm
like okay wait a minute now it's just
complaining about vegans like no it's
literally just saying vegans have low
blood I know hold on you know I think
it's fair to say there's a decent of
people who go on diets so don't plan
properly exactly it's like probably the
vegans that are in that category don't
know what they're doing and I think I
think it's fair to say there are a lot
of vegans who do out there doing yeah if
you if you want to change your diet from
what you're used to in society you have
to do the research and the work and I
think it was like you said you said it's
not for me
I feel sick when I add it and it's like
that's good that you acknowledged it so
you you know what works for you about it
I'm not saying veganism for everyone but
do the research but you don't do the
research that's all it is just do some
research I don't I think one of the
challenges is actually that you're kind
of swimming upstream you have this whole
culture built around cheese and beef you
know plopped everywhere it's an
everything so here that's your easy well
so here's the thing like for me it's
really easy to get a lot of my like
daily requirements because every store
sells a lot of the basic components yeah
if every store or focused you know it
was focusing on what your diet was what
vegan it would be really really easy to
be vegan I mean it's really really easy
to find vegetables so yeah but like to
get your b12 to get your iron to get
your you know the things you need I mean
b12 is one of the few things that's hard
to find because it's actually it's in
dirt and it that's right animal you get
it so you get it from dirt no I mean I'm
kidding him that like mushrooms with
dirt on like that right but now we were
washing all our proto's with like you
know
watch that's killing everything yep so
we can't naturally get it anymore and
you know it's funny even animal products
don't have b12 in it so this whole thing
that you know meat eaters give these oh
no no most this Jade eaters aren't
getting b12 either so check your levels
you bulb in your life I'm serious she
doesn't believe you that's fine I did
you because because they're adding it
after the fact pumping it in with
another thing right serious actually one
of the things that you they fortify it
yeah exactly so all these things they're
just for to free fortifying it's not
naturally occurring
that's kind I'll bring up some article
about research right I love it do some
research do some research I don't I
don't know what I want I take B I take a
big complex every day I feel greatly my
books did you look up the mandala thing
yes McDonald's fries oh they like put
salt on them yeah I feel like add salt
too well that's a weird comparison like
it is Burger has twice as much salt as
those fries there's a weird comparison
okay hold on I think it's fair to say
that the McDonald's burgers themselves
probably have more sodium in their own
fries well why wouldn't they can compare
it to another burger that's yeah it's
weird I don't get it because I think
there's ragging on you for being vegan
bro yeah maybe they're just like
honestly that's okay screw you rag on
yeah I don't mind because I feel healthy
and I'm happy in my life so that's what
that's that that amen
you know we're all about liberty here I
know the way I say it is you do you I'll
do me
like I always say look I tell people
this was my favorite way to say it I
don't care if you wanna dress up like a
clown
walking around juggling bananas mm-hmm
the moment you start throwing the
bananas at people so I get a problem
with you exactly if you want to be vegan
I don't that's it's your yeah I don't
want to throw anything at anyone throw
vegan burgers and people
authoritarian veganism not gonna work
old people doubted what are you
Harrison and the sodium in a McDonald's
burger is 745 milligrams and then the
impossible burger is 1200 oh wow Wow
can you look up what's what's your daily
sodium intake that is a lot 1,200 for an
impossible it's almost boiling fast-food
yeah seriously miss just avoid fast-food
don't don't try to kid yourself that you
know this plant-based burger at at
Burger King healthy with your onion
rings no vegan is out there going this
thing is the the healthy burger that you
should eat no no no one's that burger
isn't for the vegans it's noggins cuz
the commercial me the commercial
literally shows not vegans be like wow I
stood in a Burger King I wanted to try
it I stood there and there was two
construction guys in front of me and the
guy goes you know what I'm trying to you
know I'm trying to eat healthier I'll
order the plant-based burger and in my
head I was like you go guy but then you
know it's like it's 1,200 so what's your
nail is worse it's worse I was wrong
yeah if you're trying to watch your
health it's like shouldn't be going to
Burger King for lunch and eating
anything there nothing there is going to
be good for you remember supersize me I
never actually saw it but I remember the
baby yeah was for a month or so yeah
Morgan Spurlock I think he made a really
good point that it's like when he
started doing it McDonald's immediately
was like no no no no no we don't expect
people to eat her every day and he was
like you saw breakfast lunch and dinner
you so if people eat every day and you
sell three three you know the three
basic breakfast lunch and dinner yeah
yeah people are gonna eat there every
day but we don't we don't expect them
down and that was the point yeah like
when you do that for your main food you
get it's not but there was that go to
the Big Mac diet where you literally ate
nothing but Big Macs mm-hmm yeah that
guy I hate a lot of Big Macs as a kid I
did like those a lot they should be big
they use there was a video there was a
post on Reddit where it shows like the
original Big Mac and he's massive really
compared to today and it's like this
little tiny thing yeah all right I think
we're we're good to wrap up this segment
yeah let's head over to some super chats
before we finally wrap up for the night
let's see we got Burt Bargo says
he protein that's actually genius don't
flush him well it's peña it's like like
pea pod
yeah peas uh a nelio Farina says
confirmed
Adam is a simp I don't know what that
means
okay do you know that means no I think
it refers like a white knight kind of
person or something a white knight yeah
I don't know what does it mean I'm sure
it's an insult it is it is all right
cool well I don't know whatever you know
we can take criticism we're adults
jinx lousy says eat both meat and
vegetable that is true balance well I
feel like I did so we I've been eating
healthier than ever in the past week
couple weeks because when we started
doing this show I was like I gotta
finish my morning segments then I have a
few hours in between for everything else
and then the night segment and I'm like
that means I need to have a I'm not
gonna go out and get fast food fried
burgers and so we had like you know we
had fried chicken breasts - a little
chicken spice some asparagus and
mushrooms today very very healthy and
delicious I got a drink more water - you
can hear it my voice
you